la première pierre de cette usine fut
posée en 1922 et on peut dire que
c'était là une des premières opérations
de décentralisation tenté en france une
opération qui était le fait de la
société du petit écho de la mode dont un
secteur quitté paris pour s'installer à
châtelaudren dans les côtes du nord nous
sommes maintenant au départ on y a un
prix mais seulement des revues telles
que mon ouvrage 1925 et des collections
de livres aujourd'hui disparu en 1944 à
la fin de la guerre la société changer
de nom et commencé à moderniser ses
méthodes de travail son directeur actuel
monsieur mercier nous parle maintenant
de la production 1968 nous faisons
beaucoup de propositions oui et
périodiques en général ce sont des
branchages ou semestriels et puis
beaucoup de pabo publicitaire est la
principale l'une de nos principales
activités et la réalisation de façon de
match représente les patrons demandent
eux représentent environ 45% notre
activité et sur la production française
ou robes ou lycées et sur la production
française 50 % du marché français
cette entreprise est la plus importante
de ce secteur de la bretagne dans sa
branche et cela ne pose apparemment pas
de gros problèmes
quels sont vos rapports avec vos
contrats aux états unis sur beaucoup
moins d'attention que vous sur le plan
matériel je passais de police vernon
rapports ont toujours été excellents et
le sont toujours nous essayons dans la
mesure du possible de nos rangs de plus
de services communs entre autres ayant
d'un atelier de photogravure intégrer
ceci nous permet de réaliser un certain
nombre de travaux qui leur sont
nécessaires
et
il vous permet également de maintenir un
très bon rapport avec le coût
pour le personnel peut-on parler de
qualification
c'est absolument indispensable
et c'est là le problème est le plus
il a un réseau d'eau pour trouver des
techniciens qualifiés et surtout assurer
leur niveau de technicité
est-ce que vos techniciens sont
originaires de la région casser les
reins des environs ait en fait très peu
de châtelaudren
cette entreprise modèle présente en fait
une gamme de possibilités très complète
les machines ne s'est jamais de produire
et rien n'est perdu tous les ateliers se
complète de la photogravure à
l'impression en passant par la
composition et la correction mais
revenons un instant au personnel féminin
cette frappe de connaître ses opinions
sur le travail au frais
voilà c'est un patron europe que vous
faites à un pyjama si vous êtes content
de travailler dans cette usine
subi est-ce que vous veniez bien votre
vie
oui capranie r combien faites-vous par
mois cette année serait vous demandez à
windham dit
mademoiselle a su vous êtes content de
travailler dans cette usine
étiez vous gagnez bien votre vie
on peut vous demander combien en moyenne
par mois
il est ce que c'est difficile comme
travail est ce que si vous pouviez
changer de travail vous changeriez
je vais pas changer librement
combien de patrons plier vous par jour
comme ça
à peu près 2000 3000 milles
voilà vous n'avez vu qu'un visage à ces
fugitifs de cette imprimerie mais nous y
reviendrons pour vous montrer comment ce
fait sa principale production le patron
de moeurs ajoutons simplement que
châtelaudren compte 13 cents habitants
et que le zino emploie 105 ans ce qui
n'est pas mal vous en conviendrez